I've been in a Senior Operations role at
my company for a number of years and I
wanted a way to kind of codify what I've
learned on the job what does this EO of
do how far off the mark is is my
capability are there things I can learn
so I was really interested being an
Operations professional trying to
understand what what an institution like
Stanford is defining CIO as I think what
drew me to it specifically was the the
bringing a strategic element to the CEO
role and having that kind of be at the
heart of Silicon Valley I wanted to work
with Sanford's faculty and kind of move
beyond all the readings that I had been
doing case studies that I had been
looking at I thought was a perfect
opportunity for for me and us as a
company to invest in continuing to
elevate the CEO role within our company
you really do owe it to yourself in to
your staff to put new information in to
be influenced by new thinking's
it's important if you're gonna get to
maximize the value of the investment
you're making to take it seriously and
you know really dive in you know as
though you were back in school it was
really important for me to step outside
my context and take in something new to
be able to come to the table with new
modalities new thinking and new
approaches there is a lot of opportunity
to learn to network to create
relationships both with our peers in the
classroom as well as the faculty at
Stanford you're looking for the things
that you can't get out of a book that
you can't get out of a podcast it's the
people it's the faculty it's the
connections that you build that really
make this program worth
you